e aí galera assistir o canal tudo bem
com você e eu estou bem eu tô vendo todo
mundo tava em 2012 eu fiz um vídeo ao
crepúsculo engraçado não gostou ano
passado eu fiz um vídeo sobre o dica é
assistir annabelle todos vídeo era mais
gosta do meu canal ea galera tava no meu
twitter me enchendo o saco pra foi
gravar um vídeo sobre 50 tons de 50
segundos antes simplesmente imitando
assim nem sem nunca entrar no ringue
tube não então por amor a vocês o que eu
vou fazer agora vou gravar um vídeo
sobre 50 tão precisa pra vocês aí você
não assistiu o filme ainda não leu o
livro ainda é uma visão que nesse vídeo
que eu vou contar várias paradas então
avisa fiquei sabendo que 50 tony cinza
era um filme do mesmo assim era ótimo né
50 tons de cinza é um filme que saiu
agora baseado em um livro e esse livro é
meio erótico então filme também seria
ótimo fiquei sabendo que era ótico vamos
no cinema megan animais urbanos trailer
bob esponja robinson giz olha pra mim
essa cara de safado mas aí começa o
filme já começa uma coisa que me deixa
puto é pra ser uma menina meio estranha
sim é negado e tal que se apaixona por
um trilho narua desgraçado é linda eu
acho incrível como enfim dos estados
unidos parece que a pessoa mais fé que
existe tem o olhar isso aí essa menina
vai entrevistar o cara que é trilionário
ricão e o que acontece o cara resolve
que quer comer o cara é trilionário ele
pode comer katy perry pode comer a xuxa
pode comer claudia leitte como ivete
sangalo ele pode me com mesma não ele
quer comer manga lloyd é aquela
personagem do mesmo jeito a zona não
nega a dar o melhor de mim ninguém me
quer e ninguém nunca me com o meu nome
da graça anastácia agora o nome do cara
christian grey opel enquanto escuta
cruise em inglês já sente com as coisas
se sente assim um início de perda de
cabaça quando escuta esse nome nunca me
arrastar se a gente não vá a mas tá se
custa hancock um negócio a ciência não
deixa anastácia não está para que este
rei assim como endereço não está para
rihanna não bati beleza ela trabalha
mercado é que o mercado negro de cor de
construção está lá ela andando pelas
prateleiras quando ela olha para frente
é instalar que extingue o ei cara com um
monte de coisa ela recomenda que ele
compra um macacão para não sujar a roupa
dele ele diz assim mas eu posso fazer
sem roupa
aí eu pensei tá desgraça é agora que vai
começar agora vai
e nada aí ele chama ela para tomar um
café e nem um regateio matar feito nem
no café é é que o café não pois pega o
café na cara mais nada não é só tomar
café e até agora nada de [ __ ] nessa
hora que estão tomando café a menina diz
que é romântica mino ouvir a outra
pessoa é o seguinte da marca dá certo
não dá certo só fica longe de mim fica
longe vinha de fora fica longe o cara
trilho natal dando bola para mim essa
senhora fica fica longe o que doeu
furava a camisinha bnb o chaveiro logo
para que logo ao sustento hora ficam
pois ela vai ficar longe sabe que ela
faça sair com as amigas ela não é besta
com as amigas thomas cachaça liga pelo
fla se o pessoal tá tá tá maluca idiota
quer saber que tu não desligue só que
ele faz ele liga para ela e diz assim eu
tô em buscar ela nem tinha dito onde é
que ela tava ela sai do bar quem é que
está na porta do barraco este inglês
aí eu paro e penso como é trilionário de
onde todo o dinheiro do mundo aparece em
todo lugar na hora que quer esse homem
ao satanás certeza que não pode ficar
tudo que o quarto lugar e ele leva ela
com o hotel já no hotel mesmo jean
a catarata rola mas não é nada não é só
o só dormi nada de [ __ ] de novo a um
ignorante
aí lá no hotel eles dizem aquela famosa
frase ele fala eu tenho um gosto
especule áries você não entenderia a ela
de então me mostra já é hora agora agora
vai agora rola né causa desgraça não
tempo tanino é o filme toda essa
desgraça combinam com come um comem como
ela tá pra entrar no filme da porcaria
gente aí vem uma coisa que eu fico [ __ ]
que pariu [ __ ] vai tomar no meu com o
cara fala que não vai tocar nela até que
ela assine um termo dizendo que aceita
que ele faça tudo que quiser com ele
quer por escrito o consentimento dela
ele quer que ela assine um contrato
machuca tipo a testar para dar bola eu
declaro para os devidos fins que meu
blog é do cinto criei na frente eu falei
isso não era gente a brincadeira até que
com meia hora de filme ele se b de
justiça eu também
ela fala a gente vai fazer amor agora
ele responde eu não faço amor profundo
com força aí num doido em mim não está
assistindo negócio na hora que ele falou
isso faz com que ela falou que foi de
vôlei não tomou só perdendo a cabeça
aqui rápido marcando boyle se prepara
tudo cara mostra tudo pra ela leva no
quadro estatutário e mostra o chicote
nosso negócio vai bater nela mostrar o
gema braçadeira morta tudo a ela revela
que é virgem a e desgraçou foi todo o
cara é viciado em dar um tapa na cara dá
um murro a menina nunca vi uma roupa
nada rola o que rola no seu carro aí
depois de muito tempo eles finalmente aí
cara que tem 17
não estava agüentando mais a assistir no
filme está com x vídeo aberto meu
celular para ver se houve alguma
portaria porque não há tempos eles dão
um ela dorme e acorda querem dar ordens
e gostou
aí também a [ __ ] que não tinha no
começo do filme tem no resto é tipo
assim oito do bom como está tudo bem
bom dia bom dia boa transar embora e aí
bota botar tudo boa todo bom botas a
bora
aí ela começa a fazer o tão famoso cubo
dos o que não é muito indicado porque é
um cara que gosta de dar um tapa na cara
da namorada a chicotada pode jogar sal
nesse com o doce dela daqui pra ela faz
com 12 faz com 12 faz com 12 faz com
doce e lhe dá um carro de presente para
ela
[ __ ] que pariu [ __ ] vai tomar no meu
cu de novo na minha gente gosta faz com
doce e quente que a gente leva um
chocolate mas não aceito é de chão para
assistir um filme bicho a cet da
floresta fácil
não quero é desgraçado dá um carro ela
fala que não quer virar a cara pra ele
sabe que aquele fire leva pra dengue
coloca no colo e dá uma palmada na bunda
da graça leva uma surra na bunda porque
ganhou um carro e um apanhado de graça
quando era criança só queria um carro
nem que fosse de controle remoto ninguém
nunca me deu um carro quando fosse
criança acaba lá para cá ela vai ganhar
um carro meu deus que é a pena viajar em
outro lugar para visitar a mãe em outro
estado totalmente longe fica com saudade
dele com saudade dela com saudade dele
manda mensagem ela quis e quer outra
bebida ela vai falar meu tempo é por um
lado quem é que tá lá com este android
o carro apareceu de novo donato falando
esse cara é o satanás e no final do
filme um desfecho 5 também não vou
contar pra vocês que portanto não vou
falar tudo aqui mas do tipo isso a etapa
é rolé murro pai comunitários e queimou
na cara e pai eu olho come todo mundo
meu amigo enquanto você estava
assistindo esse filme christian gay como
você para você se divertir se você tiver
gostado se faz saber que esse daquele
curti-la no facebook é compartilhar
também ajuda muito a marcar um amigo nos
comentários encarar as steve klein legal
e se você está aqui no youtube você
clica em gostei e clicando em buscar um
maior incentivo você pode me dar que
assiste todos os vídeos do canal que
assistir qualquer vídeo novo e como é
que assistiu comentando o filme ou
música alguma coisa é só clicar em
inscrever-se que está muito obrigado
você quer assistir sido até aqui é nóis
se você quiser me seguir no twitter me
seguir no facebook não está grata a tudo
aqui embaixo na descrição do vídeo
valley é nice